let's talk about a
healthy way to because i want to give
you guys actual advice right i mean like
when i
when i started broadcasting the show i
mean the whole point was to help you
guys avoid making a train wreck out of
your life
and i didn't say it at the start of this
show but this is the only show on the
internet that will
show you how to avoid making a train
wreck out of your life and i'll give you
some actionable advice here so
let's use the example that you uh
provided where
she goes out with the girls for girls
night out
so she's got all dressed up she's got
her little black dress on she says
hey paul i'm going out with the girls
tonight let's
assume that you're in a conventional
monogamous relationship hey
my answer is who are you bringing home
to me right right that's why i had to
say that to make sure we
you know we speak to the mass level of
understanding here so
um you know she says hey paul i'm going
out with the girls tonight
and uh i'll see you when i see you right
so
conventionally you might look at that
and say well that's unusual why is she
going out with the girls and
your and your firmware like your hard
wiring your dna
every part of it's looking at her going
okay she's getting dressed up she spent
three hours getting ready she put on the
high heels
the little back dress the spanx the
push-up bra
she did her hair she curled it she put
on the makeup she's getting ready to
market herself is what your dna is
starting to say
so the little you know electrons start
firing and they're like
and they start talking and they go okay
buddy you might have to start going and
make guarding might have to start going
in jealousy mode
right the point that the guy made
earlier about jealousy being beta is the
conventional way that most guys would
get jealous
where are you going who are you going at
with where are you going to be what time
are you going to get back
well call me when you get there right or
maybe he'll start calling her phone and
blowing up her phone when she gets there
that's kind of the beta way you know to
deal with it the
way that the conventional alpha would
deal with it would he would just
basically look at the scenario and say
women with husbands women with
boyfriends whatever
don't go out for girls nights out and
that's it it's just a firm boundary
you know it's as straightforward as as
that the smarter guy would be
attentive to her uh cycle and
of course know when she's an estrus
because if she's going out when she's
ovulating that's when women cheat the
most
okay they don't cheat when it's netflix
and chill night and they're on their
period that's not when they do it
so the smarter guy pays attention to it
that way so that's the difference
between the two approaches right
if you want some actual advice in that
area do you want to um you want to add
to that or do you want to go to number
four with the existential despair
yeah so um you know i do want to add
that a little bit so
it's really important that i'm not
advocating here that we eradicate our
jealousy instinct
because um because because it's
over stimulated so that's really
important there's
a mythology out there that of course
claims that jealousy is a beta trait
and that in order to be somehow woke or
higher level or a better man
you have to eradicate that instinct to
the point where some guys eroticize it
i mean they're dropping off their women
to other dudes houses
you know and writing blogs about it and
writing blogs about it
i can believe that crap when i looked at
that i was like what was this guy
you know and that that is somebody who
is taking an
instinct that's designed to protect you
and
it's even if it's not about paternity
she can't
really have that love for you and i say
love it's kind of a container word but
that aw and that respect and be in your
frame and have
everything that you would want in an ltr
she is not going to give that to you if
she doesn't see you as her best
and has her apex alpha if she is making
this is a really important distinction
if she is making the decision to sleep
with another dude in that moment whether
she's right or wrong objectively
subjectively in her head she thinks that
guy has something you don't
guys we can sleep with somebody that is
half as hot
and she fell asleep you know drunk next
to a dumpster
and we're gonna sleep with her because
we're men we just spread c
that's our you know that's our strategy
women though are hypergamous they're
always looking to level up
if they see you as her apex i mean
there's certain circumstances like that
are outliers like revenge cheating or
circumstantial cheating when a guy is
gone for a long time
stuff like that but generally speaking
if she is with somebody
and she decides to sleep with someone
else instead of the guy she's with
it's a statement that that guy has
something better
or something that her partner doesn't
have so that is a direct threat to your
alpha frame as a man
a direct threat to who you are and that
is not that is a recipe for destruction
and failure in a relationship
which is why when we talk about harem
stuff or polygamist
which is the male you know version of it
i'm not one who ascribes to letting
being okay with your woman sleeping with
other men because they're so
the way that they select is different
than the way that men select the way we
make
you know and so and so that's very
destructive for them to do that
and so we want to use our jealousy
instincts to our advantage
but we have to have control over it by
recognizing
we're on overdrive like and our a
tendency is going to want to do
avoidance behaviors
to not face it or to fall into nihilism
because it's so despairing we can now
get an existential despair
okay or to behave like a convict and go
you know throw a guy through a window or
something at the bar she went to go the
girls night
out or something crazy that would end
you up in jail
you know we we can't do those things we
have to do something much different than
that
and that's the alpha man will have that
control what's that yeah here's a
comment
um from one of the channel members he
said interesting topic on the beta moves
when women step out of frame and men are
looked at as weak for confronting them
they're only looked at as weak if
she wakes up in the morning and looks at
this guy is he's not my best choice
if if a man stands up and says
a woman with a husband doesn't go out
for girls night out
and she stays there it's fine you know
she's only going to call him weak or
controlling
or abusive if she doesn't see him as his
best choice
if she sees him as his best choice can
be you know what you're right i
shouldn't be doing that
that's that's not what married women do
i'm going to stay here with you tonight
or we're going to go and do something
else together
um now if she goes out on her own if you
don't want to look weak
fine she goes out of her own you set the
boundary she she stepped outside of that
boundary
have her [ __ ] and bags on the front
porch with the locks change when she
gets back
or go out yourself and do whatever you
want you know it's entirely up to you
but
disappear for a weekend yeah or
disappear for a week and then stop next
for a bit whatever but yeah it's a good
point to
kind of you know kind of hit on
you